voilà concrètement dès aujourd'hui ce
sont 300.000 hommes supplémentaires qui
pourraient être appelés par Moscou
entrer en scène pas de mobilisation
générale mais un appel aux
professionnels aux plus aguerri
gotirabinsky bonjour on décrypte ce
discours cette intervention qui s'est
fait déjà longuement attendre pendant
toute une partie de la nuit très vite
différentes chancellerie je viens de le
dire on réagit il y a une onde il y a eu
Berlin qui parle de de mot grave
prononcé par Vladimir Poutine et puis
d'autres voilà un aveu d'échec de
l'opération russe comment est-ce qu'il
faut interpréter cette prise de parole
du président russe aujourd'hui
oui l'aveu d'échec épatant mais je
dirais ça n'est pas aujourd'hui ça n'est
plus ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il faut
manifester et bien isoler c'est le fait
que Vladimir Poutine et dans une
rhétorique qui justement lui permet
pense-t-il de contourner cet échec
militaire et cet échec militaire pour le
contourner et bien on est sur le terrain
il est sur le terrain politique et je
remarque une chose que nous n'avons pas
trop signalé jusqu'à présent c'est que
le référendum les référendums évidemment
vont aller dans le sens de la Russie ce
n'est que qu'un artefact rhétorique
quand il dit il faut soutenir la
proposition du ministre
des Armées ce qui est totalement stupide
chez Hugo n'oserait jamais faire une une
pareille proposition s'il n'avait pas la
valve de Poutine mais de toute manière
ces référendums qui seront truqués dans
lequel les les électeurs seront conduits
fortement à voter pour les Russes sinon
il risque de représailles et bien dans
ce cas ça veut dire que quand il y aura
annexion de ces deux républiques par
exemple du don-bass
à partir de là il y a des combats il y a
gain de terrain pour les Ukrainiens
Moscou considèrera qu'il s'agit d'une
agression contre la Fédération de Russie
puisque c'est territoire seront annexés
à la Russie c'est là que ça devient
dangereux et puis bon on l'a dit il y a
la question de la menace nucléaire qui
n'est pas anodine puisque Poutine dit
c'est du bluff et là soit l'Occident
considère c'est pas du bluff pardon
Poutine dit c'est pas du bluff si
l'Occident considère que c'est du bluff
et bien on continue à dire c'est la vœu
d'un échec oui seulement le problème
c'est que dans la rhétorique de Poutine
on a plus et on le dit à chaque fois il
n'y a plus complètement la rationalité
ce qu'on croyait pendant 20 ans
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'il y avait une
manière d'avoir prise sur Poutine à
travers la rationalité du commerce du
gaz etc ça n'est plus complètement là et
donc à partir de cette position que peut
vouloir Vladimir Poutine si ce n'est
défendre à tout prix ce qu'il considère
comme essentiel c'est-à-dire l'idée de
ce chauvinisme grand Russien et son
discours je terminerai là son discours
est aussi destiné à récupérer cette
frange du nationalisme russe qui
commençait à douter de lui et donc par
l'affirmation de ces non seulement
exigences puisqu'il dit on ne combat pas
l'Ukraine en combat l'Occident c'est
très fort ça ce qu'il a dit et bien par
l'affirmation de ce type d'arguments
c'est une manière de regagner le camp
ultra nationaliste alors justement quel
pourrait être la réaction la réaction
des Russes assez propos il y a déjà des
vidéos qui commencent à circuler de la
garde nationale ruse qui commence à
aller chercher un chez eux des
réservistes comment les risques vont
réagir à cette annonce de mobilisation
alors d'abord c'est une mobilisation
partielle il a dit je le répète c'est à
dire qu'une mobilisation totale
susciterait probablement pas forcément
un
mais une telle résistance et réticence
de la part de ceux qui ne veulent pas y
aller que ça serait pas temps et qu'à
partir de là on dirait mais non les
Russes sont pas derrière Poutine Poutine
le sait d'autant plus qu'il y a cette
terminologie l'opération spéciale si
Poutine avait confiance dans ces
citoyens il dirait c'est une guerre elle
est justifiée en des nazis donc c'est
une guerre non il dit opération spéciale
parce qu'ils que derrière il n'y a pas
complètement adhésion alors par exemple
vous avez des vidéos qui circulent sur
la question de savoir comment on peut se
casser un bras pour échapper à la
mobilisation vous avez un certain nombre
de personnes qui sont
juste à la limite et qui disent non il
ne faut pas y aller et puis si on y va
dans quelles conditions est-ce que les
réservistes seront suffisamment
convaincus du la justesse et du bien
fondé de cette action pour y aller donc
ça veut dire qu'il y a des réticences
qu'il y a une prise de conscience
probablement qui ne sera pas suffisante
dans l'immédiat mais qui qui gêne
Poutine même dans sa façon de contourner
encore une fois la question militaire
merci beaucoup Gauthier pour